ça fait 20 ans que la télévision
montrent des homosexuels totalement
caricaturaux ils font les queer il met
benjamin bove tu jettes une analyse
génial et je l'adoré si tu veux et great
de la capture d'or ils font un secret
story 4 ils ont beau noix du bois qu'on
adore [ __ ] il écriture est rurale fait
partie de notre hélas écoute moi bien ça
fait 12 ans qu'on demande à danse avec
les stars que deux garçons dansent
ensemble et quand deux garçons dans son
ensemble qui dansent sébile al hassani
j'ai rien contre millas la ceni mais
pardon un mec qu'a une perruque et des
fossiles je ne me reconnais pas dans ce
style de gay alors c'est vrai que ça ça
fait énormément parler mathieu est
derrière quelque chose derrière derrière
déferlement de menaces ok qu'est ce que
tu as reçu comme comme comme message peu
importe les menaces j'ai demandé au
producteur à nordine ci peut passer la
photo je vois là de bilal assadi voilà
que je lui ai envoyé
là il ya cet après midi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé voilà que oui a répondu guy
lacroux j'adore - il le sait les adore
de la série a contre lui alors je dis
juste que ça fait 2 tf1 n'a pas
découvert l'homosexualité en 2021
l'émission à 11 ans qu'ils auraient pu
faire danser jean-phi janssen il aurait
pu faire danser emmanuel moire non comme
par hasard ils ont fait maintenant avec
vécu avec un homme mais seulement
répondant c'est un homme avec un homme
c'est quand cet homme est grimé en femme
alors encore une fois je suis en train
de dire que ben homosexuels pardon un
homosexuel c'est pas quelqu'un qui a une
perruque des fossiles avec les mines
obert et europe m passez moi la photo i
mean europe et alors peut-être six ans
il est supposé nous représenter
chaîne d'europe première chaîne d'europe
il est supposé nous représenter voilà
est-ce que ce garçon représente une fois
ci soient dénoncés rien ne
tolérant envers tout le monde vient de
chances qu'on vit une époque accompli je
pense que ça là c'est malvenu sur toute
ta part de juger tout ça alors 6 evans
toujours demandé pourquoi je vois dans
la caricature et pour ne pas me alone et
les aînés on doit justement le montrer
l'exemple en étant solidaires les uns
avec les vertus cette épreuve c'est très
civique tu sais quoi c'est dit quelqu'un
qui est en province voilà qui ne s'est
pas déjà vu tout le monde mais peu
importe quoi à paris en banlieue voilà
les parents sont avec les enfants mais
c'est pas très bien ce que c'est qu'un
homosexuel papa c'est quoi mamans
homosexuelles et ben voilà bah c'est pas
grave regardons ce avec les stars un
homosexuel c'est ça c'est un monsieur
qui mène des rues ya des faux cils et
qui s'habille avec une robe non non
c'est pas ça non sexuel
y en a beaucoup mais comme par hasard
tf1 choisi le caricatural le pourcentage
ça c'est un pur sang rien du tout photo
jo preuve c'est que tu t'arrêtes à vous
êtes un cul
tu estimes tu estimes tu dit bilal est
caricatural moi j'ai vu des garçons qui
sont répandues sur les réseaux sociaux
en disant je ne t'autorise pas à dire
que je suis caricatural parce que je me
reconnais en bilal parce que j'ai envie
d'avoir des cheveux longs ou parce que
j'ai envie d'avoir du maquillage je ne
suis pas caricatural je suis un
homosexuel et je vis mes
cheveux courts il aurait été bien
habillé comme un garçon n'aurait pas
fait danser avec un garçon a coûté vous
êtes focus aval de la tv d
obliger nicolas kind avec nous et
animateur sur un petit je suis assez fan
de nicolay énorme incroyable
transformation et c'est que là tu dors
vraiment je l'adoré il est incroyable il
a un talent fou est-ce que ça a été vrai
que les propos de mathieu sont choqués
alors ça m'a un peu interpellé jeu là
vous en faite il ya une chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que bilal ils ne
représentent pas les gays mais oui en
gros la seule chose qu'il faut retenir
c'est publie la liste reprise sur lui
parce que c'est un artiste dans une
émission de variétés de divertissement
et en gros il se représente lui il a
envie de s'habiller comme il veut il le
fait la seule chose que ça offre
c'est une visible et et à la diversité
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les gens
pensent sa télévision je t'ai laissé
parler tu me laisses parler aujourd'hui
les gens qui sont devant leur télévision
hier j'ai reçu une dame sa fille était
jeanne leurs fluides elle a cru que
c'était une maladie j'ai dû lui
expliquer par émission avec deux temps
par aller je suis très ému j'ai dû lui
expliquer par une source n'est pas une
maladie qu'elle devait accompagner sa
fille qu'elle devait être soutenant tend
vers sa fille parce que sa fille ait les
32 elle et elle avait besoin de
s'exprimer elle avait besoin de
comprendre qui elle était de trouver sa
voie
aujourd'hui un bilal assadi qui va aller
dans dalle c'est qu'il va danser avec un
homme gère déjà pour la petite
parenthèse on a eu déjà des gays qui
nous ont représentés comme tu dit
représenter landale qui ont fait le
choix de danse avec des femmes
aujourd'hui on a quelqu'un qui danse
avec un homme qui a envie de ce mets des
talons des fossiles bah il le fait il le
fait très bien il le fait gracieusement
et au final ils veulent faire et il va
montrer à des jeunes qui regardent la
télé peut-être à des parents qui sont un
petit peu catastrophé non mais je te le
dis alors moi je te le dis mais tu ne te
regarde mon interprétation sociologique
que l'on fait et très bien je rêve dans
la vraie vie tu sais ce que ça va donner
je connais des gens qui vont être devant
leur télévision et qui vont se dire
madame c est les guerres les savanes et
ça va créer de la violence et sur
l'allemagne laisse mal finir je suis en
train je suis animateur sur m6 ce
week-end j'étais en talons aiguilles aux
folies bord en train de de d'animal
d'animer la soirée oui ensuite j'ai déjà
leurs fruits dans mon salon qui sont de
très grands artistes et je suis ravi et
je suis ravi parce qu'ils disent que
c'est la preuve qu'ils peuvent s'assumer
n'est pas d'enseignants de personnes je
crois mais regarde justifier des talons
je mets des rucks péruvien les gens qui
m'écrivent et kim deal enfin on peut
assumer
juillet coexister jeu j'ai eu alors moi
je
parlement il ya pure sur twitter je suis
dit mathieu le pauvre il doit passer une
soirée qu'elle passe difficile de sa
touche au corps moi ce qui me touche
c'est que effectivement il y as je suis
d'accord avec vous au temps de guerre
qu'il n'y a personne est gênant juge
aucun je dis juste que comme par hasard
dès qu'on en prend à la télé on prend
celui qui est le plus caricatural et
gênes
avec une robe qui mène faty méfie toi
comment en quoi il parle quand même pas
mal investi les mines robe lilas des
polices il laisse faire les ongles une
perruque que ce sont les trois premières
chaînes sur la première chaîne
bbc2 l'ouverture aux agressant fédéral
estimant que n'importe quoi vous savez
ces femmes qui sont extravagantes mais
je vais les liens très cross
hasard il choisit alors que caracas et
j'espère ici si je
connais parce que s'il vous plaît c'est
que le premier qui dans sa cale manière
plus souple et n'aurait pas posé leur
propose un homme j'aurais dit oui sur
les
habillait alors guillaume genton était
d'accord avec moi tu veux juste que je
voudrais dire sur mathieu mathieu quand
j'ai entendu la matière a si ça n'a rien
à voir mathieu là il se met à la place
de tf2 mathieu et il dit comment ils ont
comme ils interprètent le casting alors
c'est pas il dit pas moi je n'aurais pas
fait ça il dit voilà il en fait ce qu'il
dénonce mathieu sait qu'il aurait
préféré peut-être qu'ils prennent bilal
assadi oui avec plaisir et un autre un
autre mais bien sûr voilà c'est ça c'est
sa vie c'est à dire exactement ce n'est
pas directement je pense quoi là il ya
les mobilisations ce qui le dérange ce
qui serait bien enrobés en enrayant faut
sinon c'est moi ça ne me dérange pas ça
pour représenter
mais c'est quoi
les réseaux sociaux on les voit sur
macintosh
évidence une nouvelle chute
des places et j'aimerais juste
comprendre c'est quoi une bonne mais
avant tout sens aigué pour toi gros des
bulles des blonds ouais c'est ça pour
toi c'est moi qui voulais parler
c'est pas ça les listes blanches où des
vagues et c'est plein de choses pour
qu'on prend forcément et on a la lidho
talent celui qui est en face avec une
robe aussi
mérité en fait on a besoin de viviez en
a besoin de diversité mana woerth afin
de valider était en train de dire que
les nécessaire de faire ensemble on
essaie de faire ensemble qui est de
moins en moins de monde vit on essaie de
faire ensemble
très bien c'est qu'on fait on montre des
la communauté
près du lac à zilina réseau noms de
santander homophobes
la macula alors la vraie question c'est
pas pourquoi ils ont dit oui à bilal
assadi c'est pourquoi ils ont dit non
aux autres voilà et au bout d'un moment
faut dire les choses faut dire la vérité
l'image de deux hommes avec une
apparence d'hommes et pardon bilal
assadi
quand il est en mode alassane sy n'a pas
une apparence de femmes l'image de deux
hommes en apparence d'hommes qui dansent
ensemble aujourd'hui ça gêne à la
télévision et je vais vous montrer une
image la seule fois où ils ont eu deux
personnes du même sexe qui dansent
ensemble qui se rapprochent ils l'ont
faire les deux femmes s'étaient alizés
et camille lucchi s'embrasser et j'avais
sorti une photo et on n'est pas dans une
représentation de l'homosexualité n'est
pas un mec là on voit les allemands très
apaisé on est dans l'hyper sexualisation
et quand ces deux hommes comme par
hasard ils le feraient pas parce que
faut pas se mentir l'image aujourd'hui
de deux hommes qui dansent ensemble et
deux hommes qui s'embrassent ça gêne à
la télévision sous la loupe les leçons
d'action plait merci alors une ondine
merci le sondage merci on l'aura
certainement ultérieurement
mais je perds c'est ce que tous les
autres danse avec les stars israëliens
américains des anglais le craignent à
chaque fois que c'était deux hommes
s'étaient de guerre parfaitement normaux
alors bon
vin 80% les gens ne comprennent pas la
polémique autour de mathieu